hey gunner Brian here with an important  announcement I am taking over comic-con  again this year but we're starting a  brand new Instagram account to do it hat  Conan con yeah we paid someone a lot of  money to think of that you like free  tickets we got free tickets you like  Funko pop figures we got back Co fun  figures you like a mystical Asgardian  hammer with immeasurable destructive  force we got that too I can't throw it  it's an expensive problem at corticon we  have it all even special guests I said  special not celebrity if you're special  change follow at Conan con get ready for  more Comic Con than ever before  let's rock  you  [Music]  you